journalism is under attack like never
before no person between tear gas fire
you have to have the facts beautiful but
tragic because people are doubting
everything you're the only way of
telling their story how would you
describe this outbreak something like an
apocalypse you're going to be really
tired you're going to be really scared
it's too dangerous anyone who says
they're not scared is lying
anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of
this we do genuinely believe in what we
do he's clearly march's press to show
the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover an injustice
this is the result of ethnic cleansing i
don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford i'm stuart ramsey and this is
hot spots
coming up on hot spots my team travel
across india as coronavirus takes hold
and oxygen runs out
they were screaming out for oxygen the
definition of a hospital struggling to
cope people who started to die in front
of us
and we're in brazil where the new
variant is causing major concerns for
pregnant women more pregnant women were
dying than anywhere else on the planet
i'm not prepared for that if you've got
500 000 plus dead these figures are
absolutely horrendous
very early on it was obvious that oxygen
was an issue
everywhere you looked there was people
desperate for oxygen
look at that it was bartering and
fighting and blackmailing to get hold of
air
oxidant cylinders were selling for 10
times the price and the crematorium is
working non-stop as the numbers of
deaths in india continue to rise
constant flow of people carrying in
bodies coming in every few seconds the
grief
in that place was immeasurable i don't
think we'll ever know the real figure of
how many people died during this second
surge
i love india it was my first bureau all
four of our children were
brought up there and went to school
there we've all got fantastic memories
of india so i was very keen to go back
i hadn't been there for a few years i
used to live there but
obviously given the story we knew it
wasn't going to be particularly pleasant
india went through one of the most
strict lockdown across the world and for
almost three months
they really thought they had beaten it
and went so far as to say that
they then embarked on a whole series
of events
they allowed the
organization of one of the biggest
religious festivals in the world health
experts have flagged this as a super
spreader there was no social distancing
no personal protection
they organized and allowed a whole
series of elections to go ahead in a
number of different states
the government machinery was too
involved in campaigning
right till middle of march the prime
minister himself was campaigning
the day before we got there the indian
prime minister was saying we must save
this country from lockdown from lock
down that was his focus
we set off knowing that we were probably
heading into the teeth of a
coronavirus storm
um what's that look like pump we can't
sing
at least we're going into the worldwide
cookie center of the global pandemic
my memories of india is a kaleidoscope
of color and people and noise and
cacophony of everything and this was a
deli that was a ghost town
it was like empty empty empty you felt
that you were landing in the middle of
some weird apocalyptic situation
even before we got there our colleague
who's bureau chief of the asia bureau in
sky neville was isolating because he'd
been to cover this religious festival
the kumbamela which turned out to be a
super spreader event
not being there with the team not being
able to be with them on one of the
biggest stories during this period was
extremely frustrating
so we had to arrange a
new producer
there was a very high number of
journalists in india who died of
coronavirus so there was a very high
degree of fear
summit was one of the few people who
would agree to work with us
this you can see is the center of delhi
i'm not sure if you guys have been here
already
the requirement for
oxygen in delhi is around 480 tons a day
and
what they're receiving is around 80.
he was very brave extremely switched on
knew the lay of the land and essentially
could speak the language
he uh headed around all the hospitals in
the vicinity
we immediately found that it was going
to be more difficult than perhaps we
first realized
[Music]
there seemed to be a
sort of decision from somewhere didn't
know where at that time that they didn't
want journalists to see the real story
security were keeping everyone back
they were in control of the perimeter so
they were stopping people going in even
the relatives who were left to cry
outside no no okay let's go to the other
one then
we went to another hospital and the
front entrance was blocked the security
guards were all stopping people how did
he give them permission
summit knew a way around the back it was
a huge hospital uh
warrens of
lanes all around it
i'm not really sure how we managed to
get in but somehow we did
very early on it was obvious that oxygen
was an issue
and as we got closer we see
there were lots of patients
outside we got closer still and they
were on
stretchers
and some were on the pavement it was
just absolute pandemonium outside
we'd literally only been there a few
minutes when people started to die in
front of us or had already died
and relatives were crying
there were too many people to even cope
with the number of deaths just right in
that small little courtyard
i i understand your father has passed
away silently
they finally got the brother an oxygen
mask and minutes later he died
tell me who do you blame for this
sooner or later a relative would come or
you know maybe a medical person would
come and they were zipping up the body
bags
there just wasn't enough time for people
to even grieve or to get used to the
fact that they they'd spend hours trying
to save their relative and then
it was over everywhere you looked there
was people desperate
for oxygen desperate for the hospital to
admit them
tell me what happened sir yesterday we
came up with our father but no one came
to see
this is your third hospital and you've
been here how many hours five hours
you just need oxygen
yeah
how much oxygen have you got left in the
hospital sir
and we were begging to get inside
so much was happening there was no one
in control can we do it from the door
but you can't take the camera
kev took this staggering shot of which
was a glimpse of the nightmare scenario
that is a pandemic
families trying to save loved ones and
doctors running from pillar to post and
despairing relatives standing by and
there wasn't a space free
it was just utter chaos in there you
couldn't see the floor it was just
people beds everywhere
and then the doors shut
and we thought whoa if that is happening
here what on earth is happening
everywhere else because this was in the
capital
it's been very close because family have
had it close friends have had it we know
people who have died um as well in this
thing so it's it's it's hit very close
and
that's the same for almost every other
family in
in delhi eventually we began working
with our colleague neville who had
finished his period of isolation and
began working with us again
it might have been that one back there i
thought it was the other race
it just feels that the whole government
have not
geared themselves up for for what is to
come
you've seen signs from america from
europe where
people have just been dying but uh
and these are this is not new it's been
known
but there hasn't been any
preparations by the government we knew
that there was a lack of oxygen we got
told that there were people queuing up
at these small industrial businesses to
try and fill up oxygen tanks we had no
idea that it was quite so extensive
oh yo
look at that
oxygen was being brought from outside
delhi you know from far off some even
you know hundreds of kilometers we've
been trucked down to delhi
there was this huge long queue
of people all lining up with their
oxygen tanks who'd been there since
before dawn
prices of oxygen and cylinders and
quadruple we were told so you know it's
it's um yeah not not easy for them but
they had no
it was choice
and fighting and
bargaining and
blagging and just trying any which way
you could blackmailing to get hold of
air because there are no hospitals there
are no beds are no oxygen there is no
preventive care there is no creative
care
so eventually we have to take care of
our own tests and what about the cost of
this so whatever that i ask i'll do it
but if you can get the oxygen why can't
the hospitals
beat me i don't know
how's that allowed to happen you know it
was the
populous
a big giant mega city that hasn't got
its own oxygen supplies
[Music]
we did go and
fix it up with this
sikh organization they'd pick up sort of
abandoned
bodies that no one wanted to touch to
the family members couldn't do the last
rides
because either they were in quarantine
themselves or they were unable to do it
so
this sick organization would do it pick
it up from hospitals or from other parts
of the city
take them to the cremation ground do the
paperwork
and then do the last rides
[Music]
is there someone who's died in their
home yeah yeah he died in the home back
foreign
and no one will come
up here yeah yeah yeah
they're literally just volunteers they
all had jobs in completely unrelated
industries
so they've been called to a home and
this is happening
well several times a day
because someone has died of covered but
no one will pick up the body
[Music]
that was hard going into someone's house
her husband yeah wow how many children
do you have
two doctors we'd seen lots of body bags
and hospitals and
actually seeing a dead body
a loved one in their own home where they
died was yeah that's quite something to
see and
it showed obviously the just a situation
of what these people had to cope with
[Music]
it's an extremely intimate
private
occasion
[Music]
it's quite a privilege to be in those
circumstances with people
[Music]
how will your family cope now do you
think
since i'm the older one
anyhow
anyways
i'll do it
i'm so sorry
delhi is a huge city absolutely massive
there are millions of people living
there so where do you point yourself
at where do you go it's like you can't
get into the hospitals very easily you
can't
get into people's homes
part of journalism is just about
sniffing something and following your
instincts you want goggles summer are
you all right all right
okay
so we turned up at this hindu premature
just to investigate and see what was
going on what is the situation on the
ground
we were being told numbers on a daily
basis but in reality just a few that you
see in front of you you know it's clear
the numbers were not being tallied up
correctly
this is pretty astonishing because
almost everywhere you look there are
ambulances carrying
a number of dead people there are
something like 42 ambulances that we've
counted that go all the way down this
road and the crematorium is working
non-stop as the numbers of deaths in
india continue to rise
along with the spike in coronavirus
cases and so far the country just hasn't
been able to get a grip on it
they just couldn't cope with the number
of of dead people that were arriving all
the time
i knew what we were going to see roughly
but it was just the sheer numbers you
know the constant flow of people
carrying in bodies there's another one
coming in coming in every few seconds
all you could see
was a haze of fires
so kev decided to put up a drone
[Music]
it's starting to get dark so we didn't
have long to get a shot but as soon as
you stick it up there it's just see
immediately the sort of scale of
what's going on
[Music]
because the funeral pyre and the way the
funerals are done in hinduism there's no
sort of pretending that this isn't a
person by putting them in a box
no these were people
i've never seen anything like that
it's when it was like churning out
body after body pyre after pyro was just
lighting and people are waiting to put
another one in
[Music]
with fires lighting
all around you
and there's just
masses of people crying and the grief
you know in that place was
i think immeasurable
[Music]
at the crematorium people who were
turning up there had not even got to
hospital so they hadn't had a test they
were not registered as coronavirus
deaths and therefore they didn't die of
coronavirus as far as the authorities
were concerned so we knew that the
government figures did not match the
reality on the ground and this was far
far bigger than they were making out
these are all terribly frightening
statistics for the residents in this
area and throughout the country and as i
say there's a very
deep worry that this could be far far
worse
if it's happening in the capital it
could be far far worse out in the rural
areas
i was
very keen to see what
how they were coping outside the virus
had reached now smaller cities towns
villages because people just traveled it
opened up people took
the virus back with them in their
villages so it's about 8 15 in the
morning and we woke up with a flat tire
which we got fixed and now we are on our
way to agra in uttar pradesh
yeah
it's a bumpy start
lockdown traffic is pretty cool
you know india is so vast
compared to when when i lived in india
before they had huge big
motorways now which made it so much
easier but still took like a full day's
travel to get to get to the heart of of
rural india
when we stopped in agara at the taj
mahal uh we were kept some distance back
but it didn't appear to be any uh
restrictions or people just playing that
barely saw anyone with masks on and even
those that had them were just around
their chins
lockdowns in the big cities like delhi
sent tens of thousands of migrant
workers back home to the villages and
that's how coronavirus has taken a hold
here where treatment is many many miles
away
we reached a very remote village
there was definitely a fear hanging in
the air because the villagers had
blocked off
the lane that passed the house where the
family was suffering
we decided to put on some protective
clothing because we're going into a
house where two people are positive
other people are showing symptoms
we want to protect ourselves but also
make sure we don't take the virus out
with us
and we knew that there was a real
scandal going on
about how so many
teachers
were dying
hi there
okay so
i think this
is a new
reason
these government teachers and thousands
of them were put on duty which meant
that they had to go to polling boats
interact with people without any social
sort of distancing or protection
they all went out in their thousands to
do this work for an election which
didn't need to be held at the height
of a second surge of the pandemic
within
a week or two weeks of coming back
thousands of teachers were getting ill
they all went back into their rural
communities taking the virus back into
areas which haven't seen the virus
[Music]
how will you manage without her do you
think yes
today
that family was a microcosm of what was
happening around the whole country
you know real sadness
real desperation real anger
you know talking about her mother was
talking about i told her not to go i
begged her please don't go and do this
election result
[Music]
i don't think we'll ever know the real
figure of how many people died in india
during this second surgery
we are the largest democracy in the
world you cannot you you have to be
transparent you have to show the numbers
i think any government might have
struggled but they seem to make a
particularly bad job certainly in the
early stages
it is a disgrace that
something as big as this
in terms of numbers and and
what went on during those months hasn't
been really talked about
[Music]
i hope
in the years to come
there'll be
historians from all different countries
doing a full in-depth analysis of
why that happened
and who was responsible for it
because
that seems bonkers
absolutely bonkers
up next
seeing
small babies in icu is just a whole
another level
you can't just dismiss what we have seen
with our bare eyes you can't say it's
not true
the p1 variant in brazil is claiming a
new type of victim
suddenly we're seeing numbers of
pregnant women getting covered and dying
rise i was not prepared for that
people are
angry
why is our country like this if you've
got 500 000 plus dead these figures are
absolutely horrendous and it's not made
up
one of the problems with reporting on
coronavirus now is that a lot of people
know an awful lot about it and they've
made their own decisions or they just
don't want to hear about it anymore and
there is so much misinformation out
there at the moment that actually one of
the most powerful and effective
tools right now as a journalist is one
simple thing it's called being there
so you can't be accused of making
something up
half a million people in brazil are
expected to have died with covert 19
before the week is out in brazil the
death toll is surging brazil has been
one of the worst affected countries
there is nowhere in the world tonight
where the virus is spreading faster than
brazil on brazil's front line the
casualties are mounting horrifically
it has a president who never took covet
as seriously as the rest of the world
we'd been there in 2020 we met up with
supporters of president bolsonaro and
literally thousands upon thousands
simply refused to accept that it was
even remotely dangerous
we're here to support our president
because he's trying to expose the truth
about kovite 19 this is more danger for
you people cannot just rely on
mainstream media
a year later over 500 000 people have
died it had its own variant
and it was out of control brazil was
actually turning into a massive
worldwide problem
we've been working in colombia and we
always knew that we were going to go
onwards to brazil after colombia there
are neighboring countries turns out you
can't just hop anywhere nowadays
colombia and brazil are neighboring
countries but it's going to take us 10
and a half hours which seems insane
because it took us 10 and a half hours
to get from europe to south america
but that's covered for you and somehow
even though we had all checked in
together no one had mentioned to us
that stuart was on a completely separate
flight to dominique and i would you
believe
one airline has two flights from bogota
to sao paulo that leave within five
minutes of each other so when we're
coming to land in sao paulo my phone
starts pinging we just landed a stream
of messages from students and i was like
you're never going to believe what
happened
i almost died
which is always so unpredictable
yeah it's never easy
stewart's plane had to make an emergency
landing and had to turn around an hour
in in the air departing from panama
because there was some kind of major
problem with the aircraft
so it wasn't the best flight i've ever
had
[Music]
it was great to be back in brazil it's
somewhere we've worked so much over the
years and martial our local producer has
become a good mate of ours
our relationships with the local
journalists that we work with have
become even closer because we care
obviously we care about
each other and we care about where they
are and what they're going through so
marcia is really one of those people
very close to our team who we absolutely
love working with the old team's back
we are back
and situation is still the same
sao paulo where we arrive to the worst
city in the worst affected region in
brazil and nothing to indicate it's
going to get any better
story we did a good year beforehand
we first showed the numbers of graves
that were being dug
to cope with the likely at that stage
covert deaths
so when we were back now we decided that
we needed to go back to the cemetery and
marcia took us to the exact same spot
that they filmed from the previous year
[Music]
looks a lot different this time
[Music]
what we saw when i put the drone up was
that all of those graves had been filled
and they were still digging
up until april they were doing
night burials
for two months you know this year
so all day and all night yeah yeah
i think those shots being merged
together encapsulate the
brazil covid story it was um
it was it was quite striking when they
dug these graves in april 2020 and there
are thousands of them they didn't expect
to fill them but they did easily and
they've had to extend in
every direction here at the cemetery
the fear is that the p1 variant in
brazil is claiming a new type of victim
somehow covid seems to be able to find
new hosts and that appears to be the
case that it's getting younger and
that's what we were seeing in brazil
much much younger people
really seriously ill or dying the first
grave i've looked at this is just a 30
year old
suddenly we're seeing numbers of
pregnant women getting covered and dying
rise and that was one of the main pushes
for us to go to brazil we thought we can
try and tell the story not in a
scare-mongering way
but to understand why specifically in
brazil
more pregnant women were dying than
anywhere else on the planet
we wanted to not just tell the stories
ourselves we wanted someone to tell
their story and that is why we started
to look very specifically at what was
happening to pregnant women and their
families left behind
so martial made contact with a guy
called douglas
who had a little baby
and two other children
his wife had contracted covid
she deteriorated really quickly
she was a healthy woman and she was a
healthy
mom to be
i was talking to the doctors only by
phone because they don't allow me to to
save her
they called me
and they say okay
the baby you burn now and you call you
sorry
what happened my baby's born
okay and my wife no your wife is not
good
she trusts not it's very bad at the ship
state
and they said because the the bacteria
went to the red and there tried to bring
her to bring her back
and afternoon
she called me okay dog sorry but vanessa
passed away
so douglas found himself in this really
desperately tragic situation where
he was now a new father to a little girl
but then on top of that
also still a father to two little boys
without their mom
she hadn't the chance to say goodbye to
her kids goodbye to her mother
i when i think about that i
i
i was not prepared for that
it was so heartbreaking to be honest
his whole life has been massively
changed as you can imagine by all of
this
he's absolutely dependent on his
mother-in-law but now pretty much moved
in and was helping live with the baby
[Music]
[Music]
m
one you don't want to intrude on these
people's grief that's that's the main
thing i don't want to cause them any
more trauma than they've already been
through
two you know you're working with baby
and i'm trying to get shots to get the
story to work and what have you
that's fine i think you can carry on
doing what you are going to do okay
oh i hope that she doesn't wake up
he's just got the kid to sleep now if
you're a parent you know how precious
that that time when the kid is asleep
is luckily for us he and his family were
really accommodating and very friendly
and you know incredibly
brave but there's no getting away from
the fact that what we do is intrusive
he was saying what really struck him was
that he sees pregnant women walking down
the street
young with no masks on and he just says
i can't find myself just going up to him
saying please put a mask on you're not
invincible
i couldn't really to be honest hold it
together when stewart was interviewing
him it was very sad
we just look at numbers of covert deaths
and then you kind of go this is
somebody's wife it's always hard to do
interviews like that
hovid
is a virus
that affects the rich the poor the
middle class everybody
you apologize for messing around with
her kitchen we met tyus who was a
remarkable young lady
she came from a very different kind of
neighborhood to douglas
much much poorer area
which just demonstrate for us you know
this virus hits people across the board
nobody's immune
can you
tell us what happened to you
i you
she just succumbed really fast she was
taken in intubated and again the baby
was delivered very very premature
she i think
realized just how close she was to death
and she realized that it wasn't just her
little boy who she just had
who would have been without a mum but it
would have been her other children as
well
my
[Music]
stuart and i were standing
on the little step to the front door and
this woman arrived at the house
there's a health worker's just arrived
going to check on the baby
she's not a scientist
but what she could tell us anecdotally
was that she was definitely definitely
meeting more pregnant moms before birth
with curvature 19 than she had done at
any time previously in the pandemic
but what we wanted was the medical story
as well you know that we wanted hospital
access to talk to a pediatrician and one
of the doctors there the force of nature
that is marcia had gained us access to
the hospital where
tayus had been
treated we first gonna film and then we
should be ready to get in close to a
nice trip
nice
we'd actually been told we weren't going
to get any interviews we weren't going
to be allowed into any awards and no
a martial doesn't take no uh never has
done
what we often find once we meet and make
a connection with people is that after
they've got to know you a little bit and
they trust you they're willing to let
you
see more than they had originally agreed
to this was the hospital that i treated
tais and they knew that we'd spoken to
her and this was the doctor who had
treated her baby so for us it was very
nice to kind of have that full picture
and for the hospital it was actually
very nice for them to also talk about
from their perspective
um
filming in icus is is challenging and
shocking
but seeing
small babies infants in icu is just a
whole another level
i think that really struck home for me
and i think for the rest of the guys as
well just the extent about this coveted
and just how it is affecting lives all
over the world and any ages and and the
types of people it's really remarkable
it took us a little bit by surprise
actually that the hospital officials
took us to a regular icu treating over
19 patients
we hadn't requested it and they had said
well actually we just want to show you
that even though the pandemic's meant to
be you know dropping off
our icu here is still full
we've seen it everyone's seen these
pictures and it's very easy to start
taking them for granted you shouldn't
because those people are really
seriously ill
it's only by us going in there and
witnessing that
that we can get across to people the
enormity of what we're facing
we knew that the
death toll in brazil was going to pass
the half a million mark and it did
and it did coincidentally on the day
that there was a mass anti-bolsonaro
rally planned
[Music]
everything in brazil is huge the
country's huge
when they do demos they're huge and
they're loud
while they sometimes turn very nasty
often you know there's a real sort of
party and carnival atmosphere
[Music]
can you hear do you think we're there
doing a news story and in the middle of
it all
the desk was trying to get us up to do
live
uh and i'm trying to communicate with
stuart he's a couple of feet away from
me and we couldn't hear each other
it could be a mission
there was just no chance it was
so loud
i mean there's a lot of people here
uh it's difficult to guess actually
because it goes in both directions and
halfway down but i mean it's tens and
tens of thousands and might be hundreds
of thousands of people don't know
[Music]
and it's fair to say there was a
cross-the-board anger that lockdown
restrictions hadn't been put in place
we spoke to loads of people and
absolutely every single one we spoke to
had either lost a friend or an immediate
family member to covid what's on our
mentality it's why we want to show the
world
our indications
[Music]
[Music]
at least four people that i know have
died by coronavirus we don't want this
we don't want to live uh under the bones
on our government do you think bolsonaro
is going to listen
no
people are
angry
like when is anybody going to listen to
us why is our country like this why is
the president still in power when must
handle the pandemic so badly for his
part president volcano says the economy
has to stay open he says people might
get covered but they'll definitely
starve to death if you kind of do a
story about covid you're going to do a
story about mismanagement of the country
by the president well the very least you
should try to speak to the president
shall we try to get out
we tried all sorts of sources we've got
through to one of his sons who's very
close confidant of the president he just
told us to basically get lost and
don't don't ring this number again
resilient
it turned out we could get an interview
with a very high-ranking congressman
who's former general and who's you know
good buddies with the with the president
so we went to to meet this general now
we didn't know what to really expect
because he is pretty hardcore
i mean as journalists we are the enemy
general the general was a little bit
tense or sort of
looked a bit unsure about us
you visited which places you visited in
brazil he's very clearly
uh proud of his military heritage so we
pointed out that uh
that richie was a former marine i
and like a transformation in the
interviews and it became really really
matey i respected so much
people from your country almost
instantaneously his whole demeanor
towards us changed he actually gave us a
really
good
wide-ranging interview and we were
allowed to talk to him about pretty much
anything but he was absolutely adamant
that bolsonaro was right that there
should be no lockdown and that covet
even though it had it wasn't that big a
deal
well he actually said that he would try
to
facilitate a meeting with president
bolsonaro who doesn't like speaking to
foreign media he doesn't like speaking
into much media
so we were hoping that we would be able
to go and
get nearer to the president and you'll
be with him then
i will be with president both
unfortunately what he didn't know is
that the president's office would
realize what we were up to and they
withdrew all our accreditation about the
next morning
i have people say to me oh but you know
the stuff you filmed in brazil surely
that's not true and it's like i don't
know how to explain
any more to people that
what we are seeing we are we are
privileged to see
because we are
witnessing reality in real time
it's very very difficult when you have a
section of society that is convinced
that absolutely everything they see is
fake unless it suits their narrative it
is false narrative coronavirus has
killed not one person that's a fact they
no longer talk about covet if you've got
500 000 plus dead these figures are
absolutely horrendous and it's not made
up but you can't just dismiss what we
have seen with our bare eyes you can't
say it's not true
this whole idea of fake news and this
whole idea that
hospital wards are empty and that the
media is lying and then you know that
mentality exists amongst bolsonaro
supporters for sure in brazil and brazil
is hardly the only country where that is
an issue
going to meet people like douglas and
tayus getting them to tell their stories
in their own words not us telling the
story i think is the best way we can get
an accurate representation of what is
happening in the world across the people
and you're just going to have to accept
that you know some people you're just
never gonna convince you have no choice
but to keep
doing it
you just got to keep going
you don't want to lecture people but you
do have to give them the facts
you can't allow people who say things
aren't true when they are actually true
next time on hotspots
as the fate of the planet lies in the
hands of world leaders at the cop
climate conference i'm in madagascar a
country on the brink of the world's
first climate famine
everyone that we're seeing here is
showing signs of under nourishment or
starvation
and i'm in peru to see the biggest
glacier in the tropics melting
you know 15 foot of ice that is now just
grass
there's nothing before your eyes but i'm
filming a clip and just crying
until then you can find us on twitter at
alex crawford sky and at ramsey sky
see you next time
[Music]
robert's got a quick hand
you look around the room he won't tell
you his plan he's got a road cigarette
hanging out his mouth is a cowboy kid
here found a six-shooter gun
you